[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of the after show today we're
going to break down day shift diving
deep on the details and answering some
of the burning questions left by the
film now we must warn you this is a
spoiler-filled show so if you haven't
seen the film turn this off now and then
come back to it once you've watched
you've been warned
and all they are is murderers
it's not eclipse new moon breaking dawn
point one it ain't like that all right
why do you know the names to all the
specific twilight films and what's your
gripe with breaking dawn part two it's
the exciting conclusion of the whole
twilight saga alongside me today i have
somebody who i always like talking
movies with especially movies like this
i will say mr j washington actor and
comedian sir welcome back to the after
show i'm glad to be back it's been a
minute you know i'm glad to be back here
with you and we get to talk about this
movie because it's a movie it is
moving are you ready for this let's go
here we go
it's a movie it happened we saw it it's
rated 59 on the tomato meter with an
audience score of 63 that makes its
rotten as far as the critics but just
barely and it makes it fresh as far as
the audience but also just barely the
critics consensus for day shift says
name stars and an appealing goofy
premise aren't enough to make up for day
shifts uninspired action comedy hijinks
so jay do you agree with the critics of
the audience on this one what do you
what do you think i'm
i'm with both because it's it's here's
why
the critics are right like it's not the
name stars with jamie foxx snoop dave
franco all it's not enough to hold it up
and the audience can see they just was
like i'ma just watch this movie and see
what happens and then they were like
well i watched it and that's what the
audience score seems to reflect because
it's just like you see we all saw the
trailer right yeah and the trail is what
got everybody like oh my god i've got to
see this is jamie foxx as a vampire
hunter snoop dogg being snoop dogg
because that's all snoop can be in a
movie and then you get all these things
and you're like cool because the trailer
show these these dope action sequences
yeah but then you watch it
and you're like so so so nothing's gonna
really happen oh okay cool this is it
all right this is it that's it um
i'm even more cynical than this i'm even
more cynical of this partially because
it's a netflix movie and it has a lot of
stars but also for the fact that it is
directed by the guy
who basically
was a stuntman for everybody
and they're basically like let's see if
we can get another john wick situation
out of this this guy also worked on john
wick four so it's just like one of these
things where i'm like i get like how
this pitch meeting happened where it's
like we got the guy that was will
smith's trainer he was jamie's trainer
he was these people he was the trainer
he was a stunt guy on blade
why
i couldn't have been in that office
because i'd be if you've been doing that
pitch i'd have been just like okay and
like
like because how does that translate to
him directing a movie like he's just
gonna keep using a yellow filter through
everything
so again i am not gonna say that i think
this movie is wholly awful because if
you went about to say we're gonna put
out a big jamie foxx wants to do a big
action comedy with lots of stunts lots
of like practical and like cgi effects
but this is gonna be like a real
give it up for me action movie it
achieved its purpose it really did
but
there is nothing else i can say about it
hey jamie
i'm gonna say this hey jamie if you're
watching this uh you already i love you
for what you do for comedy what you've
done for a lot of communities i will let
me preface that
now
i'ma need jamie foxx to start playing
more people than besides jamie foxx in
movies
because if it's not an actual character
a real life person jamie doesn't go into
the roles it's literally just yo we told
jamie foxx hey man we're gonna put you
in some joggers and some hawaiian shirts
and act like you work as a pool dude and
you killed him right that's literally it
yeah no i disagree with that he was with
the michael b jordan movie from a couple
years ago
that was not him and he does do that he
doesn't do it
i feel like it's not fruitful for him
and so that's why he ends up going back
to these roles because like after ray i
think that experience he wants to get
back there you know he was he's an
oscar-winning actor and i know that
this is him saying like look this is not
maybe happening right now let me just
have some fun he was look okay i hear
you with that with the michael b jordan
movie but when he played django it was
jamie foxx as a slave he was too cool
for school as a slave and like you get
this man i mean that was what that's
what quentin wrote i mean he originally
wanted will smith for that exact reason
he wanted somebody charismatic he wanted
somebody and maybe will smith wouldn't
smack chris rockefeller to play django
but that's not the point we want to
bring up right now we don't know what
would happen but what i'm saying is
this is just i didn't see any i'm like
yeah jamie wants to do action and
different things and i just didn't see
it i felt more of the comedic element
all through this than anything else like
the action sequence is the best no that
dude you can tell has been working out
for this
working out like i'm saying jamie ain't
working out look the best action
sequence to me out the entire scene of
the entire film is this before we get
into the action sequence let's go ahead
and just start with the premise itself
let's do that just why don't you go
ahead and just level set us on the
premise and then also whether or not you
think it really works because look i'll
actually level set us on and i can tell
you if it really works so this is the
idea of jamie foxx's character was part
of the bounty hunters of vampires in los
angeles so he's a part of that crew and
he's been banished because basically he
was wild now back at a time when he
should have been wilded out but he needs
to get 10k to keep his daughter who he
has with megan good in town so he's like
i got you a day shift and snoop dogg is
the brother that gets him hooked up that
right there is when i'm like this is
also why i'm like they're just having
fun snoop snoop and jamie were like you
want to do a movie because let's do a
movie that's all this was wow exactly it
was
it was 10k like he could just the
problem was put your daughter on the
screen i get to get the lead character i
gotta get to the other league character
there is another person in this movie i
know we've only talked about jb fox but
so he gets partnered up with dave franco
who plays his partner um on their sort
of endeavors to go you know his first
day on the day shift and dave franco's
character was actually a pencil pusher
sort of an office version of the bounty
and he's getting out in the field
setting up our odd couple premise of the
very by the books dave franco and the
i'm willing out everywhere jamie foxx
all right now you can while out on the
premise okay
he needed 10k to keep his daughter from
moving put that little child in a public
school to call it a day you were in the
valley there was a public school down
the street from my house they were in
the same neighborhood i'm in also
i can see what dave franco's character
okay i want to be a head pencil pusher
that was kind of wild that was his whole
goals and aspirations he wanted carol's
desk he didn't want to do nothing else
but at carol's desk and snoop is a black
cowboy who by the way nobody told him it
was going to be 93 degrees every day you
shoot because snoop head on all the
layers okay how many layers of clothing
do you need to put on while you're
smoking all the weed it just it
you know you got you got dave franco's
character who's like supposed to be my
hall monitoring jamie foxx every single
thing he does he's every little
violation he does jamie foxx is like hey
i'm just going to kill everybody so i
can make this money and i'm going to
pull out their teeth because there's a
pawn shop to just buy vampire teeth i
was like wait what do you understand
when you talk about the pitch of certain
movies in this one we gotta also include
the fact this pitch involved a lot of
alcohol and cocaine because every little
thing the head vampire which we're going
to get to in a second she was a vampire
who's now a day walker blade ain't got
no originality no more she could just
live and sell homes in the valley in the
daytime
this is the one thing i will say not to
like take up out against it because i
wanted to see like kind of who was
involved in this one and really maybe
sort of dissect exactly
where it is and so like it's in this
action comedy genre and the writer on
this one or i should say one of the
writers on this one has like a lot of
experience because it's the john wick
writer as well as the writer of army of
the dead another sort of like action
comedy so i feel like that is the only
area that it works well as opposed to
the vampire stuff like first of all
these are like the least it's not that
they're not cool vampires but just on
the vampire cool meter they're very low
they're zombies they're all just zombies
they're like it's not really what i
would consider vampires i mean they they
are vampires they're not zombies but you
know what i mean no they were more i see
i just saw him with fangs i didn't see
really nobody like maybe two people got
bit the whole time you see what i'm
saying like you didn't really get any
vampire type traits and tactics that you
would expect when you hear a vampire
movie
no i mean that's again why i say it
works more on the action comedy side of
it than the vampire side of it but
i can't like pretend that it's not there
just because it is part of the ethos
like i guess what i would say is
i don't think they cared about whether
it was vampires i'm sure it was maybe
even to your point zombies originally
and they just didn't want to make it
look like another zombie movie what i
was about to say is this movie feels
very chopped because it is so heavy on
the action comedy i was like well who
wrote this and the guy who wrote it yeah
he did army of the dead but he also did
john wick and those movies have like
humor to them but they're not exactly i
don't know what you would call it
they're not
they're not movies that don't understand
plot and structure and they really do
like move it along even through all the
action i just wonder why this one like
it's almost like i feel like all they
wanted to do is like improvise on set is
that what you felt with it or well yeah
they had it there was there were a lot
of times a lot of sequences where it was
just about the funny dialogue more than
anything else
it was like we got to get these jokes
out
exactly
don't give me wrong funny jokes
definitely definitely funny jokes and
we'll get to that but i i do think the
only thing i will say well how did you
feel about this and at first i'll ask
you between dave franco and jamie foxx
like where did you feel their chemistry
sort of lied because i will say
that was one of the more surprising
aspects of it for me
at first i was like how is this going to
work when you see the first when you
first introduced to the two of them and
as it builds and develops to the point
where it hits the level of course it's a
spoiler thing where he loses his head
when jb fox cuts it off and then i was
like wait this is what we're doing for
real and then we have that level now of
him as a vampire in a sense i was like
okay i see where this is going i'm all
about killing vampires my partner's a
vampire now so it kind of you saw it
kind of happening i actually expected
the daughter to become a vampire hunter
to be quite honest with you yeah
i mean that whole premise too of them
kidnapping the daughter towards the end
i also thought was a bit contrived if
i'm gonna go ahead and say it like come
on like i knew that's where it's going
but i'm just like
why
you did the same thing i did you look at
it you're just like wait why is this why
is this happening like i get it i get it
like the minute you see that little girl
like you know that that's what's going
to happen it's almost like the same
thing you saw the first time you saw
lethal weapon and you see roger's
daughter walk around in that room and
you're like this is not going to end
well for her nope nope and it's
christmas and it's christmas no
exactly exactly so like i get that but
it just it felt so contrived on it but i
will say what i was gonna say is dave
and jamie did have genuine chemistry
together and obviously i think both of
them were involved in the production of
this one so
i think that also has something to do
with it again when people want to get
together in hollywood especially more
recently under the netflix umbrella they
can do that like they can get together
to have these i wouldn't even call them
necessarily vanity projects as much as
these are not necessarily things that
outside of that structure i think would
have gotten greenlit
of course not i don't think i think you
have to have a big production studio
that doesn't really have much to lose
per se netflix doesn't have much to lose
at the time that they commissioned this
not now maybe but at the time that they
commissioned this it was it was a lot
more i think freewheeling with the
things that they commissioned yeah of
course you saw all of because now we're
seeing all of those movies come out
we're getting we're getting all of those
movies that they commissioned they were
like netflix is gonna make its own whole
slate of its own theatrical films that
come to its platform and we're seeing
all that so like at the time they were
just like oh this is us getting these
big stars to do movies for us and jamie
foxx clearly has a deal with netflix
doing a bunch of stuff you know this and
he had to she had a show please that
don't embarrass me et cetera et cetera
and like i said when you talk about
again going back to dave franco and
jamie foxx's relationship
that was a good chemistry the two of
them had it worked because it was like
oh no i need you to help me oh god i
gotta help him again at this point you
guys you see jamie foxx getting upset
with him till again when he cut his head
off i was like oh this is this is gonna
happen now then we're gonna go really
comedic hijinks now with the him telling
his body over here grab my head grab my
head put my head back on all those
different things so
hey look i won't i won't in any way say
that anything that they did that was
like that where it like grabbed my
attention or made me laugh that it
wasn't enjoyable nothing more so than
snoop like swooping in there in that
moment just to like save the day that
had to have been in his contract it had
to have been in this contract hey first
of all shout out stupid make sure look
i'm gonna represent the west side no
matter where i go and i'm a gang bang as
a bounty hunter for vampires i said what
how that was in his contract snoop i got
to have my blue flag if i wear anything
else
i mean
the man it's like he used to like run
away from it and now he's just like they
didn't catch me yet they're not going to
stop me
snoop is 837 years old still gay right
hey you're like
yeah really
but again it worked because again this
is snoop dogg you don't expect some
oscar so i'm some oscar-worthy
performance from snoop you know what i'm
saying you're not looking to snoop going
a movie you're like oh my god he'll give
us the greatest performance ever you
like snoop don't be snoop let's just be
real you're like snoop is going to be
snoop and you cool with it and where he
played his role at his final when they
had him like doing the stunt double
because he clearly wanted him doing
flips and kicks and everything i was
like oh my god and that was also
something they actually i think i liked
how they leaned into that obviously a
movie with this many stunt people they
could have hidden that better and it was
like very much they're like no no no
we're gonna make sure you very much know
this was not him
yeah you're not for the dodo calvin bro
to do no spinning heel kick in the air
and so they leaned into the fact that no
one was to believe that it was him
if they were like you know what let's
just let's just look we're doing this
right this is what we're doing we're
doing it all the way do some of the
stuff i'm not trying to take away from
stu because he really does have like
that dramatic entrance and a lot of the
stuff but it's just not
as believable as some of the other
stunts even with dave franco dave franco
also
did a lot more than i expected yes he
did yes he did he really did like he
absolutely i think relished the idea of
being really physical fit with this
honestly i think he was just trying to
make sure his wife wasn't the only one
that like gave her body for her art
because she did glow because he's
married
like kicking butt on that and like it
really like changed who she was in her
physique so i i think this is his glow
moment as it were uh also another woman
i mean tangentially talking about
allison free the villain in this one was
carla souza
i don't know
she reminded me of you know what she
reminded me of she reminded me of
malakith from thor the dark world did
you really do the dark did you do the
elf
she's like that it's like very like i'm
like saying things to like nobody you
know what i mean like she's not
not until the twist do you really even
know what she's really doing this is
true it's a lot of her like in rooms
talking about how badass she is and she
wants to go get this and she wants to do
that and i'm like
is that it
look
i'm all about what she did everything
when you found out that the old vampire
in the beginning is her daughter i was
like wait what because then you find out
how old she is and you're like this
doesn't make sense to me whatever let it
be i'mma let it be
but the best part is when she is
fighting jb foxx at the end first of all
when did jamie foxx become super strong
because she threw that man through a
brick wall and he got back up popped up
popped up like it was christmas like
what up oh like yo
like in between takes that we didn't
know about also to every woman who i
know was pissed at this one thing where
she ran down the hills of them random
louboutins it was like you for the dip i
was like
don't what part of the budget was like
yeah i need at least two pairs of
louboutins one weekend to break the
heels off of because that was just i was
like what was the point i mean at least
she broke the heels though she broke
like honestly actually i'm gonna push
back on this i think women would rather
she broke the heel no
vampire and is you know as rich as f
than if they tried to pretend that that
woman was racing
in heels because i don't think they
wanted another giraffe in other words i
would just say bryce dallas howard in
jurassic world with everybody's likes
exactly but also you know you had things
with her it was just like okay what's
her plan to turn everybody into a
vampire and it was like this through
real estate like i didn't get it i was
like how does this work
and then
again i'm just sorry i'm going back to
bright like it's very much that it's
very much we've like got in this like we
roped all of the vampires or whatever
together in their own little special
area it's like why is everything just a
different version of like 1950s
segregation stuff it's so weird like why
is this the stakes in these movies it's
so weird and class structures and like i
get that i do get that and how that's
appealing on like a very basic surface
level but it really feels i'm just like
oh my god why are you trying to like
copy and paste oppression
the fact they literally did the
armenians in glendale for anybody in the
los angeles area glendale is a
predominantly armenian area and they had
armenian vampire letters who have
cleared out glendale i was like so we
just go go all the way with this like
you say surface level
just
and it's not even saying that
it doesn't add authenticity it just
feels like you're just like let me just
like do a sampling of these people's
little weirdness to like
like fill out the richness of this very
shallow shallow story it just ugh
i'm not about it as much
the the one thing i will say i like
watching the vampires die dug that liked
the whole tooth extraction aspect of it
there's something to be said for how
much you've seen vampires brutalize
humans to see humans brutalize vampires
i don't think there is something to that
conceit and that i will say is a very
entertaining aspect
of this premise and so i i enjoyed it
what did you feel about the vampires
playing the dust why is it as soon as
you become a vampire you are an expert
in every level of martial arts i do not
understand this as soon as you get
bitten now you can fight on a whole
nother level no one ever talks about
this you were a wreck a high school dude
a regular dude as a pool boy you was a
regular woman just going shopping and
now you got bitten and become a member
of the undead and your martial arts
acumen shoots through the roof you know
what i'm saying that was the thing i
didn't underst i never understand that
with any of these movies but the way
they brutalize these again the nazarian
brothers when that scene when they go
through the house and i was like oh my
god you got axes and and the way they
flick i need a bullet toss me a bullet
and that was one that was a beautiful
action sequence to me now like i said
some action scenes were dope he throws
the bull in the air catches it in the
pistol [ __ ] and then shoots i was like
okay all right and then just like it's a
lot of first of all it's a whole bunch
of vampires in a random house in simi
valley i digress again
because like they're doing like the
valley valley like this is the other
thing like most people talk about the
valley and they basically mean like
studio city or like north hollywood like
we're making this very granular but i do
really have to explain this to people
that's what this movie is like this
movie is basically telling jokes for
like 50 people in l.a
it's like and anyone outside of the land
why is this so specific it feels
it's weird it's kind of weird you want
to go to the northridge mall what no
exactly it's so that i'm like you can i
don't know i i mean i get it but this is
the thing so paul thomas anderson very
much like always films in the valley and
granted i know comparing paul thomas
anderson to what we're doing here is
like comparing the waldorf astoria to
like del taco but listen
sorry that was a comparison
exactly and i stand by that
i stand by that but no so if you're
looking at it that way you can tell
that's in the valley without it being
overt about it there's ways to sort of
capture what there is to say that
there's a valley vibe to that instead of
doing exactly what they did which was
just absolutely insane to be like this
one it just shows how people in la think
they are literally the center of
universe look we got to know you're in
resida you're in tarzana you went to
chatsworth you went to northridge every
city in the san fernando valley some
people have never heard of in their life
now they know of and i think that's the
thing
like now becomes a tourist tourist
attraction when they come out here
i mean again i'm not gonna like pretend
to say that there aren't cool things
about living in la but a movie like this
which doesn't even like say like we're
gonna do one part of la like in sino-man
or we're going to try and give you the
vibe of something like valley girl this
one that just takes a smattering of just
random desperate things with the idea of
throwing them together making it feel
like something is just i don't know not
something is as much fun to watch as it
is to pitch because i say again this
movie had a great pitch meeting just
looking at the names involved these are
people who like make movies happen and
they all got together and said we're
going to make this this
meeting this was a pitch meeting at a
party this one in a board room this is a
[ __ ] meeting at a party was like yo i
got all the drinks i got the food truck
coming through i got my dj at the back
yo just meet me at the barbecue we finna
talk on the patio
break out put the printer set the
printer up with the contracts that's
literally how this meeting for this
movie came yeah and again not going to
pretend and say that i did not enjoy
laugh and giggle with so many aspects of
it but i'm just looking at this movie
and i'm like am i gonna remember this in
three months probably not one of the
reasons why i will say it's not
memorable is although the visuals had
interesting things to them like i said
about like brutalizing vampires and
like you said the great joke of dave
franco's head disappearing is there a
single
aspect of the visualization of uh
computer generated images in this that i
found to be even remotely memorable
no
like
how did you feel about the cgs cgi
effects
i got so wound up in the practical
effects i was like oh heck i'm more cgi
cause like the practice
and then the cgi just it was it was like
okay
that was the thing that's actually a
perfect uh analogy for this movie the
practical was so good anything that like
paired physically with anybody doing any
stunt action was great and anything
where it felt like okay we have no other
choice but to use cgi i was very much
bored or
taken out of the narrative and that was
like so sad because the practical was so
good because we haven't even really
talked about it which we're going to
talk to about in a second the stunts and
the practical go hand in hand as far as
like how that was exceptional compared
to the rest of the movie again the
opening seven minutes of this movie when
you see jamie foxx's the pool cleaner go
in his house when they start telling you
things okay vampires will be just keep
they'll keep the blinds closed and have
a bunch of air conditioners which we in
the valley are in a flex alert you can't
have three air conditioning units how
you gonna do that you're just gonna kill
probably oh my god quit making this more
about the valley
i'm sorry i was like
but no people are going to be like can
we even understand this episode if we
don't live in the valley no you can't
you're going to have to wear things you
know you haven't going to end the older
lady because again we saw some of that
in the trailer but to see it all flush
out and in the other everything the
stunts in that were beautiful i go back
to the zaryan brothers when he was in
the bowling alley all the stunt work was
great in this when it was practical
effects with that because this was like
something they took time with they made
but again the director is the stunt guy
from john wick and we know what we see
there you know these other movies so
again we're expecting a high level in
that and i was very appreciative of it
no look and i i mean again it's the
thing that we didn't talk about the most
and i think honestly if you're really
saying when this film it's interesting
that both the critics in the audience
score is pretty close and they kind of i
think have the same opinions about it is
because look i think that's 60 is a lot
of the things that we sort of glossed
over but are very solid which is the
practical effects the stunts and the
chemistry between the leads
that can carry a lot of people and it
almost carried critics to calling this
one fresh so it's like i i know we have
sort of like
ragged on maybe a bit on the existence
of this and how if it didn't have these
people involved that could like command
this kind of stuff like snoop and jamie
and dave and all of that it didn't have
all those things
might not have worked but because it
does it it does
let me ask you a question here with that
if it doesn't have the leads that we've
named and this is a regular movie done
the exact same way do we even bother
watching it
i say yes because if it doesn't have the
leads that it does it's everything
everywhere all at once and they can
actually get to like what the essential
of it is and they can do it at a very
small budget and they can really like
drill down to it okay it's the it's the
epicness of this with these big stars
that inflate its budget and its stakes
and you can do a small fun action comedy
as opposed to trying to doing a great
big one
that requires a lot more to make it
happen
even when that's done well it's the nice
guys look at the nice guys great movie
action comedy big stakes but because of
the stakes it just it wasn't enough and
if it would have been smaller it could
have made money yeah because it was over
inflated with talent they've cost a lot
of money
and then they also wanted to be very
period and like really up the production
and
it's like this it goes hand in hand you
caught you almost can't ask what it is
like to have one without the other
because they always kind of go hand to
hand yeah i agree i agree with that um
the next thing i will say though is um
because they do they do have those three
elements that sort of like carried it to
this genuinely
mostly favorable score with pretty much
anyone else is there like genuine
moments i've already talked about mine
um i think you've already talked about
the opening seven minutes do you have
something outside of that that you would
sort of call to
as like a favorite or standout moment
when he found out the neighbor
was a heather was setting him up the
whole time yeah
when he talked even about like there's
two twists actually in this one yeah
when she was saying about because again
he me oh you're a nurse okay cool blah
blah blah then find out oh this is why
she's being set up and then she just is
thrown into the whole it's so crazy
because once he realizes she is
explaining the whole premise okay it was
the whole thing
like remember not everybody's seen it
it's not just you watching this is fair
this is fair
so
jamie's character of bob jablonski which
first of all what
the name i digress
jesus be strength he so he lives in an
apartment complex and he finds out he
has this cute new neighbor who's a nurse
she invites a man you know you think
that something's going to happen with it
nothing does then he goes home one day
it's a black dude sitting there with one
eye okay you know this ain't good
because any black dude one eye is never
a good thing just never has been asked
most people's uncles then
he all of a sudden finds out that she is
working for the head vampire lady that
is trying to kill him to set him up
because
i guess she was though she was wasn't
familiar at one point then she got
turned and she was like i didn't even
want to be this and so he's like okay so
they're fighting back and forth and
she's just so calm while he's trying to
fight her which is the best part of me
she's like yo would you calm down and he
just tried to throw everything up she's
like i'm trying to tell you what's going
on and then out of nowhere there's a
coming it's like all right well let me
go ahead and help you kill her huh what
like that's it
yeah
that's it
it just happens like that i'm like wait
wait wait wait
what because it was like there was like
you were introduced
here she is it's just right into it i
would say that that was a twist that
they had from the beginning
but the only thing that clued me in was
that the actress who played the neighbor
was a little bit
more elevated than you would think for
that role i'm like this heaven has to
show up somewhere else that's kind of it
because we should not cast an unassuming
enough actress for that one because that
absolutely trying to find her name real
quick but yeah i had it i had to pull it
up on my screen because i was like yeah
i gotta remember her name because she
played the character of heather and i
was like okay tasha louie yes yes and
this is the reason why because she's not
known here but she is known she's done a
lot of stuff in australia and she's like
well known there and so i'm like
basically what i'm saying to you she may
not be known here but she did this movie
called guns and kimbos which is great
she did the voyers which is great okay
she did the society tv series remember
that one yeah
she did the today's the daniel radcliffe
guns tied to my hands movie yes she did
guns of kimbo she also did um the
greatest showman so like she's not
this isn't her first rodeo
but like you said it's if she was
someone that didn't have if not even her
background her credits if her look
wasn't just popping off the screen you
would have just thought all right this
is just a random neighbor he meets you
wouldn't have thought anything of it
but you see her and you're like
wait something's gonna happen with that
yeah someone's gonna be a part of that
with her and also one more thing
we forgot to talk about the chase
jaclyn the chase where he has his
daughter
okay so after the main vampire lady
figures out who she is she tells who
jamie foxx is she tells him she's gonna
take his family right plain and simple
so jamie goes to pick up his daughter
paige
and when he picks her up he tells her to
get in the truck
puts her in the tightest of harnesses
tell her play your tablet put on your
headphones daddy's going to do his wild
driving
what this child has been involved in
several car chases
and honestly you wonder why the woman
don't want to be with him
you wonder why the woman don't want to
be with him
legitimately the minute you said that i
was like i see why you're like i see why
this is happening yeah you [ __ ] me at
all daddy's gonna do his wild driving
like that she is leaving to the leave
states for this reason forget the 10k
that is the only thing that you can do
to save grace she is using the school as
an excuse
when the little girl wait jacqueline get
a little girl after she sees and
realizes it gives him driving tips
starts helping him
oh to the left dad i was like wait what
did he shoot oh god there was a part
where he shot all four his tires out to
drive his car under the thing and still
drove home
oh my god yeah i don't remember this yes
the the tires going i mean again
even with the car stunts let's remember
john wick starts with the car that was
all part of that too
it wasn't just the kicking and the
punching and the dog um avenging
there were other driving stunts and this
film like pays off on that and again
that goes back to again the matrix days
same thing yeah i definitely want to
make sure we get into sort of like the
afterthoughts and like yeah with the
film
because look i don't think these guys
would be mad if they got to do another
fact and look army and the dead got a
sequel like that
so
not saying that also that netflix
couldn't maybe make it happen so just
gonna put it out there not saying it
needs to be a thing but it could be a
thing do you think a sequel is something
that this could happen it left the door
it left too many doors open before it
not
yeah it left it do you think it's good
no that's not what i said i know what
they would like
do you think this could happen
no that's a different question because i
think we still are waiting on a bright
sequel if i recall correctly right we
sure are we sure are i don't think this
gets a sequel because if the budget for
what this was was already high just to
do a sequel would be astronomical
because again we talk about big names in
this movie you can only imagine how much
bigger they're gonna try to go if they
were to do a sequel and then netflix is
already like so this movie cost us 386
million dollars
and we lost subscribers like that's how
would it go so
yeah no i i completely agree with that
and i completely agree with that uh
again we've already talked about it a
little bit but
i think this and i'm just gonna leave
this sort of like the bow of the
conversation is the epitome of why
netflix is having its struggles it just
it's just
it just completely personifies it even
more so than some of the other things
that people would point to like the
irishman or don't look up
even with all of that you just have to
look at a movie like this and just say
like
this is why
red notice and this if there is an
indictment
on netflix's spending ways this is
exhibit a and b you just sit there and
do that look just go
this is a and b and this is not to even
say that these movies are bad movies i'm
not even saying that like on its face
i'm just saying
spending money like this is like why
this is why it's not sustainable because
it cost
so much
for these so many stars
that budget whatever the budget was for
day shift
is taken up in snoop
dave franco not snoop excuse me jamie
dave franco
and the stunt work
yeah that's where the budget is and the
cgi and the cgi and yeah yeah oh no
don't get me wrong
i don't know if this is true or not but
i think that there is an
element of cheapness that people assume
with cgi and compared to a big action
sequence that goes wrong and you can
only do it once
so yeah i i i don't want to say like hey
this is the nail in anybody's coffin by
any means but i do think if we're going
to do a postmortem of like
has spending gotting out of control
again exhibit a like through the day and
exhibit b is going to be the rest of the
movies that still have yet to come
because again we still we still got more
of the game we talked about red notice
we talk about the irish we talk about
all these netflix original films that
spend all this money six underground
extraction therefore oh my god i forgot
about
it
underground oh my god i completely
forgot about six underground that right
there
that was just dumb
money that was a giant music video
that's all six underground was and you
get we talk about this spending so again
when you look at day shift all you're
gonna do is again like i stated bring in
more high name talent but also up your
stunt practical and cgi budget
and now
the one thing i will say is
it was a quick turnaround too
so this movie was announced in october
of 2020 and then shot in april of the
next year
that's pretty quick
again the pitch meeting happened at a
barbecue
that is so quick
because it doesn't take if you look at
all the settings and all the scenes
where everything is yeah they might give
you b-roll at different places but they
didn't use a lot of places i guarantee
you
i mean look they i mean obviously they
filmed it in l.a this very much feels
like a movie where they were like
we may have some l.a credits
and we need to use them oh my god i feel
bad for saying that that's so wrong i'm
glad everyone got to enjoy having a good
time making it because it looked like
they did and we're going to leave it
there
j washington sir
um but also before we go though and
thank you again for joining us it's
always good to talk these movies with
you where can folks find you and uh
where what are you working on so where
you can find me is on twitter and
instagram and tick tock at mr j
washington m r j ay you should know how
to spell washington the mad titan
podcast where i get you caught up on all
the things happening to marvel and dc
live action cinematic universes it's
barbershop talk for nerves come on in
the convo every podcast from and
september and september i start in
episode two but september 9th american
gigolo premieres on showtime i will be
in episodes two three and eight so you
can catch me in those
congratulations sir american chica low
with a little recurring yes yes yes
sir that's thank you thank you so happy
for you i can't wait to check it out
that one's already on my like cue list
so i'm excited to see that and as always
we want to thank you all for watching
and be sure to check back with us for
another episode of the after show